hey guys i'm here with yuko Nakamura who
just lost obviously a very difficult and
inspired game against Magnus Carlsen
were you struggling this whole end game
or did you feel like you were gonna draw
it um well I think if the start was very
unpleasant to say the least i'm in i
basically just made a couple of really
stupid moves in the middle game and then
after that which is all all really
unpleasant to say the least but yeah
somewhere somewhere around this point
when Magnus start going for this h5 h6
idea i started getting optimistic and i
thought i had good drawing chances um
and then he found this you know amazing
wine with King takes off 65 or more
importantly found this a for King e4
idea was just I mean just unbelievable
to say the least because I was so sure
that there had to be a way to draw at
that point but I mean maybe maybe it's
just one of those on games where it's
just you know total study and there's
nothing you can do but it's just uh you
know it's just surprising cuz I don't
think I should have gotten to that point
to begin with so to get to the point
where I was basically uh very close to
drawing the game you know and then to
lose like that's very disheartening but
um you know it happens sometimes in a
way does it feel less bad to lose since
it was such a beautiful idea that not
easy to see um well I don't know I mean
I made a couple really stupid moves like
i said in the middle game and then
magnus didn't played as precisely as I
showed up so on one hand yes on one hand
no because I mean I think probably
Magnus had gone for one of the other
ideas instead of what he did in the game
he actually would have won probably two
hours ago instead of just now but still
I mean credit to Magnus II found this
great idea at the end because like i
said i was i was almost certain that
that end game had to be a draw once once
you want for this hyeh looks idea but
y'all just have to look at it later well
you're still in good standing in the
grand chest turn you seem pretty relaxed
and chill considering you played this no
almost seven our game disappointing how
do you maintain that composure well it's
it's quite easy you just focus on
tomorrow it's not not that hard I mean
I'll probably spend a half hour looking
at that end game and you know assuming
it's losing I'm just gonna shake my head
because it's I mean it's just really
hard to believe but like I said you know
tomorrow's a new day I'm
it's really this tournament I'm just
trying to get ready for you know certain
tournament march so fed up and down days
but today was a down day but hopefully
I'll do all master ons all right well
good luck to you and thank you guys in
the studio it's been a crazy seven hours
and a brilliant endgame tactic there by
magnus carlsen